walk him to this video playing GTA chess
ok nope no begin four and down okay an
Italian game maybe he's playing the
Evans if he's playing into GTA style the
Evans probably would fit okay so never
regular mainline JUCO piano Italian game
quick before plate so it's not not
happening so often it's not bad i mean
you can do that with a quick queenside
expansion
hmm young b5 not quite not quite clear
to me if there's a threat there's a
threat involved can I just play Bishop
you six maybe I'm just on getting the
bishops off you know just have Queenie
seven here covering the e porn sb5 is
threatened some way I don't think so
really i can even simply retreat aha
okay maybe he was afraid that I would
play g5 maybe okay Queen takes a look
takes maybe rock cakes
yeah this b5 idea it's always somewhat
somewhat annoying mmm can I now my
kingdom to school I just I can just play
night to d8 actually you can take and
there may be windy a porn but they have
a very active position jack is just
doing that
yeah the problem is said this is the
thing it's hanging on on a seven
very materialistic but maybe you can do
that if it takes our places six cents
ugly but I need to keep the night of the
bishop on a seven other than that I
don't have any any kind of play
remarkable
while he's playing everything instantly
it must be very easy position to play I
don't I don't really agree with that but
ok so i have some i can i can take on d
to now and then what is this play play
Knights 96 aww yeah maybe
takes 96 take that quinte son okay
so I want to peace with 96 of course
tricky at least tricky I have bad bad
bad piece on the aid of course our core
you can take on a fade of course i
didn't i didn't see that actually he
takes on a weight Queen takes Queen a 7
no this is this is just just good for
white probably why at the end that's
Queen d6 intending work d one mate and
attacking the night maybe something else
or this and then Queen f2 at the end but
he's got Queen everyone
mom maybe maybe still Quinn everyone
takes takes and took a form that very
tricky
can can play all kinds of museum because
of my open King position
and don't tell me it's disconnected to
know
not quite sure what he's doing him
see just letting the clock run down and
I don't know I don't really think this
is clear though I mean he can take take
a seven or am I missing a window
something i don't i don't really don't
really get it ok maybe maybe here i have
some some good move he's not threatening
a judge the check here so i can maybe
play something to to go on a line
warning queen a 3 as probably ridiculous
um but Queen d6 might be might be good
with rope d1 the Queen on a seven is not
protecting f1 white forfeits on time now
I don't know what he was doing there
really letting letting the clock run
down I received a message ok I'm not
from the opponent ok and that was really
weird I mean probably why this white is
winning here but um he should have a
defense against that but I don't know
when I computers not convinced really
interestingly enough it likes black and
that's surprising
yeah Knight takes rook and eggs and now
it gives this one and here what's now
Chad actually it the computer wants to
play we should be hm interesting there
which I didn't consider it all with an
equal position quite obviously this
should be eight okay I took and this
seems to be a good for wide yeah okay
well the point is him the queen is still
covering here so he can just retreat 23
is good for wider damn like that check
check and why discern a porn up and with
a good position yeah but some no it's
just to win under normal circumstances
yeah it was very weird that he spent
like two and a half minutes here I mean
maybe it was really looking for for for
some made or anything yeah I don't know
it a bit strange because i thought this
this was rather evident that you should
do that maybe he was thinking I had made
or something no I was I also had an
elucidation I forgot it after the
capture I had this idea originally but
this is not working at all he can just
take it and and this even is even
promoting
yeah very a very weird game complicated
yeah I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching